Передати Києво-Печерську Лавру Православній церкві України  -
петицію з таким закликом на сайті президента підтримали понад 25 тисяч українців.
Олексій Кравчук, автор петиції звинувачує Українську православну церкву Московського патріархату
в антиукраїнській позиції та вважає, що держава має розірвати договір оренди з нею.
Мені це близько, тому що я хотів би прийти до Лаври,
побути там, відчути це святе місце, але в місці, в якому з'являються антиукраїнські речі,
в якому я відчуваю агресію,
я відчуваю себе некомфортно. І не тільки я, але й багато українців.
Петицію Олексій Кравчук написав 15 квітня, під час епідемії коронавірусу в Україні.
За його словами, УПЦ МП у цей час поставила під загрозу життя і здоров’я багатьох вірян.
Адже попри карантин намісник Лаври, митрополит Павло, закликав їх ходити в храми.
Ці кадри публічних богослужінь DW відзняла в одному з храмів святині
в час, коли публічні зібрання вже були заборонені.
Релігійний експерт Руслан Халіков припускає,
що таке нехтування законами України могло б стати однією з причин
розірвання договору оренди з УПЦ МП.
Приводом для розірвання договору оренди має бути порушення договору оренди,
але, як ви знаєте, цей договір не є публічним,
тому, відповідно, я не можу сказати, які там умови прописані.
Але в загальному може бути причиною для розірвання договору оренди,
наприклад, систематичне порушення прав громадян і здоров'я громадян.
І зафіксовані випадки порушення карантину
теоретично могли б стати причиною розірвання договору оренди.
Крім того, орендарі Києво-Печерської лаври порушили закон про охорону пам’яток архітектури,
адже почали незаконне будівництво на території святині.
Про це активісти заговорили ще рік тому,
коли і виявили понад двадцять тисяч квадратних метрів забудови.
Це може бути причиною не лише розірвання договору оренди з УПЦ МП,
але й внесення Лаври до "чорного списку" ЮНЕСКО.
Втім, тоді жодних рішень про скасування договору оренди не ухвалили.
Не ініціюють перегляд договору в Мінкульті і зараз.
Ми не маємо таких повноважень, очевидно, що це має бути на іншому рівні,
це має бути розглянуто на засіданні Кабінету міністрів,
дані відповідні доручення, і, якщо це питання постане,
то, я переконаний, тут мають бути зібрані значні якісь погоджувальні наради, робочі групи.
Андрій Юраш не вважає, що нинішня влада
зможе ухвалити таке ж швидке політичне рішення, як у 2013 році уряд Миколи Азарова,
коли Лавру за кілька днів передали у довічне користування УПЦ МП.
Напередодні приїзду патріарха Кирила
було реалізовано блискавичними, навіть не стаханівськими,
а я б сказав сталінськими темпами, коли за пару ночей
було втілене це розпорядження
Бо навіть з точки зору процедурної і формальної
79, якщо я не помиляюся, приміщень,  різного типу і рівня, які знаходяться у нижній Лаврі,
передати і оформити всі папери - це просто нереалістично.
Але це було зроблено, і, зрозуміло, це, власне, приклад такого політичного рішення.
Президент Зеленський постійно демонструє те,
що хоче дистанціюватися від цієї теми
і хоче показати на особистому прикладі модель розмежування церкви і держави.
Та навіть якщо влада й почне процес перегляду договору, він не буде простим.
Так, рідна для предстоятеля УПЦ МП митрополита Онуфрія Чернівецько-Буковинська єпархія
вже відреагувала на петицію.
На своїй сторінці у "Фейсбуку" запитала у вірян, чи готові ті вийти на захист православних святинь
у разі підтримки президентом Зеленським петиції.
75%, а це понад 4 тисячі користувачів, відповіли "так".
Опитані DW перехожі на вулицях Києва здебільшого підтримують передачу Лаври УПЦ.
Хай передають до православної, звичайно, до нашої, української.
Не під Московським, звичайно. - Ні, під Московський не треба!
Я проти Московського Патріархату,
я за Українську церкву і за службу українською мовою.
А мені все одно, до якого патріархату. Всі в Бога віримо.
І ця "дельожка" кому вона потрібна?
Я до цього якось байдуже відношусь. Мені все одно.
Чи хай залишається, чи...
Я тільки за те, щоб ПЦУ передати, звичайно.
Ми ж українці і живемо в Україні. А в Росії хай буде по-іншому.
Давно треба забрати і віддати ПЦУ.
А то там таке виробляють, що далі нікуди.
Проти конфлікту, який може виникнути через Лавру, виступає і отець Георгій.
Свого часу він працював у Лаврі помічником та спікером попередника Онуфрія,
митрополита Володимира Сабодана.
Нині перейшов до ПЦУ.
Востаннє в Лаврі був кілька років тому,
але відвідував лише музейні та виставкові приміщення.
Мені бачиться Лавра як осередок спілкування між різними людьми,
представниками різних конфесій, які вважають це місце святим і важливим для себе.
Я думаю, що цей період консервації і закритості МП він рано чи пізно мине,
тому що світ стає більш відкритим і більш прозорим.
Навіть якщо українська влада знайде причини для перегляду договору про оренду з УПЦ МП,
навряд чи це питання розглянуть зараз.
У період економічної кризи та війни на Сході України
розпалювати черговий конфлікт ризиковано.
Наразі ж петиція перебуває на розгляді у президента.
А на сайті глави держави тим часом зареєстрували іншу -
аби Лавру залишили у користуванні УПЦ МП.
Збір підписів ще триває.